how did we get here
let's roll back a few days
[Music]
this is cern the nuclear research
laboratory
on the border of france and switzerland
it
features the most powerful particle
accelerator on earth
the large hadron collider or lhc
what does it do well it accelerates and
collides particles
at 99.99 percent the speed of light
and maybe it could produce
the very first lab-grown
black hole
how big would that black hole be
what precautions would you need to take
not to get sucked in
and how long would it take to destroy
the entire planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a black hole opened at cern
ah black holes
gravitational matter devouring monsters
traveling across the universe on their
own terms some of them are so big
they could gobble up the sun in a day
could scientists create one of those at
cern
theoretically yes
but could a lab-made black hole be the
end of earth
let's see
[Music]
the lhc is a 27 kilometer ring of
superconducting magnets inside
it accelerates particles to move at
almost the speed of light
these particles are bound to collide and
when they do
they produce enough energy to create new
particles
we're talking about very small amounts
of energy here
the numbers are so tiny that scientists
came up with a new unit of energy to
measure particle energies
at that scale it's called the terra
electron volt
14 teraelectron volts give you new
particles
one followed by 19 zeros of
terra electron volts would give you a
black hole
[Music]
already picturing doomsday scenarios
that's very much in the spirit of what
if but
that's not how it would go down
[Music]
if one of the experiments at the lhc
ended with
scientists creating a black hole
that black hole would be microscopic
as in quantum level small it would have
a mass
about 40 million times smaller than the
e coli bacterium it wouldn't get out of
the accelerator
and rampage across the planet chewing up
everything in its way
well it could get out but because of its
laughably small gravitational pull
it wouldn't attract a single piece of
matter
the black hole would lose its energy
through what's known as hawking
radiation
long before it could gain any
substantial mass
as if it never existed in the first
place
[Applause]
even when folks at cern build a next
generation lab
the future circular collider that will
outpower the large hadron collider
will still be pretty safe for a
lab-produced black hole
to potentially cause any damage it would
need to have a mass
of at least zero 0.000 zero
two grams that's about fifty times
smaller than the mass of an ant
it would take that black hole nine
octillion years to reach the size of one
kilogram and another decilion years to
swallow up the earth
the whole process would take longer than
the age of the universe
i'd say no need to worry about it at all
the earth doesn't get destroyed every
time physicists do something cool
unfortunately but if
something does go wrong and you find
yourself
one-on-one with a black hole don't panic
tune in to our new show how to survive
there we've got you covered for any
life-threatening scenario
to help you survive whatever awaits you
[Music]
you